from the trenches of the Somme to the
battlefields of Iraq and Afghanistan
they put themselves in harm's way so
that we might be safe but more people
than ever are being publicly unmasked as
Walter Mitty's by genuine ex-service
people you're genuine right
even asking me that question is is it
rather something here this man turned up
to a military March last October in a
uniform Sky News has verified as
mismatched and wrong the badges on the
uniform were stuck on with superglue
where as you would expect badges to be
sewn on the scrim net around his neck
you wouldn't wear that that sort of what
features in the likes of Dad's Army as
the law stands it's not illegal to wear
a military uniform you haven't earned
and that's something a group of
anonymous internet vigilantes want
changed they say they've exposed more
than 3-hundred walter mitty character
since 2012 for exaggerating or simply
fabricating a military history
maybe it's the legacy of Afghanistan or
perhaps just the consequence of social
media but for whatever reason more men
and it is almost exclusively men
pretending to have served in our
military now that's wrong of them
there's no doubt about that and you can
see why so many service people and
veterans find it so offensive but do
these people really deserve to be
humiliated so publicly Richard Lee
believes he was unjustly exposed you get
your Commission on day one so from day
one of joining you become a second
lieutenant and you refer to yourself as
a second lieutenant and as as a raw
marine military sources have confirmed
to Sky News that Richard Lee served as a
Royal Marines officer from September
2007 to October 2008 but he dropped out
before earning his Green Beret we had to
get the police involved in numerous
occasions we had to actually have the
police stationed at our house they were
making extra patrols we had people
trespassing on our property he was named
by the group after his race company's
website marketed his military
credentials so I believe it's factually
correct here and the term and the
prominence within the page is not the
great amount and it wasn't didn't appear
on our page for a long period of time
the walter mitty hunters club deny any
mistake in exposing Richard Lee but
excess air soldier Phil Campion
questions how some groups name and shame
people
I do hundred percent get where this
stole developing comes from but to gang
up and you know store like expose people
and do it to the degree of Mickey taking
that they've done banter or not banter
for me takes it a step too far sometimes
it's a psychological game of hunter and
hunted many people question any form of
vigilante justice and the lack of
accountability that goes with it but the
Walter Mitty hunters Club says until the
government passes a law to stop people
wearing uniforms they haven't turned
they'll carry on doing the job they feel
the authorities ought to Shonda Lee Sky
News